the topics we're going to cover with the
panel tonight are both boards of
advisors and boards of directors and
differentiation differentiating between
the two and addressing the question
question Tania is - when you get one and
when you get the other how are the roles
different how are the functions
different what do you look for in the
boards of advisors and boards of
directors how do you compensate so we'll
get into the meat of in a minute do you
guys each one introduce yourself a
couple of your GSB alums a couple of you
aren't and talk about your role some of
you are entrepreneurs who have boards of
advisors and directors and some of you
serve on these boards but quick
introductions I am the CEO and founder
of juniors comm it's a product a
software product that's delivered
through a web browser and its aim is to
help organizers of informal groups do a
better job of coordinating their
volunteers that's what we do
i majeski alum class of 88 I'm Evelyn
Jill saver I am a graduate of the 96
Stanford executive program I retired two
years ago from Schwab where I headed up
the Charles Schwab investment management
which is the mutual fund arm of Schwab
and I serve on boards I'm on three
public company boards and three
not-for-profit boards and I also served
on two advisory boards for start-up
companies my name is Liz fetter and I'm
actually a graduate of The Temper School
of Business at Carnegie Mellon educated
back east and I am I've been a
three-time CEO both public and private
companies one was a start-up and
currently I am on three public company
boards two advisory boards of startups
and in the chair of the board of
trustees of the University in San
Francisco
my name is Alyssa Rapp I am a class of
2005 out of the GSB not so long ago I
founded bottle notes calm and online
wine company immediately thereafter and
have thus had my own Board of Advisors
and board of directors for four years in
that time I've also joined the board of
trustees for Hubbard Street Dance
Chicago one of the country's preeminent
modern dance companies so I've gotten to
see a little bit of how the other side
works but it's been can speak to when to
start that board and how invaluable they
can be a little bit of a quiz can you
talk to the difference between a Board
of Advisors of Board of Directors in
terms of the role white entrepreneurs
should pull them together how the
difference between the two anybody in
technology for me the Board of Advisors
has been more important than the Board
of Directors my board of directors still
is myself and my husband just because I
can find him and get signatures whenever
I want to and we haven't done a major
round the financing we've been angel
funded to date so we haven't really
needed the structure that the previous
panel was talking about but my Board of
Advisors really has been instrumental
super important in getting many things
off the ground in changing direction and
helping me decide on a very important
topic so for me that has been the
experience and I would say that a quick
answer I look at board of directors as
my boss I look at Board of Advisors as
my friends and
that's kind of how I think about them in
my mind
thank you I you know was not a
technologist 26 years old at the GSB
starting a company never had had been in
politics before business so I felt it
pretty darn important to surround myself
by really really really smart really
really really well experienced folks so
from the beginning we to our angel back
that raised about three million dollars
to date but for the firt from the very
beginning day one even we were at seed
capital stage of less than a million I
formed a board of directors of outside
directors and I think in some ways for
signaling purposes since I pulled in
Jack Cakebread one of the fathers of
Napa Valley and Jim Cooke one of the
founding team members and Netflix given
that our original strategy was sorted to
be the Netflix of wine I think it really
blended extraordinary credibility to the
to the venture and I actually like
Mozilla you think of it think of board
members as friends I don't demarcate
between directors and advisors in that
way because my earliest folks were
outside directors so there was a very
healthy they weren't early they weren't
investors in the company they too were
there just a cheer and coach and guide
they had a different fiduciary
responsibility but they I have a very
close relationship with with both when
we got to the next round of financing
and you know an individual wrote a
million dollar check and wanted a board
seat for it that's when I have had my
first director on the board for whom I
do technically work and that has changed
the dynamic and it's I feel very
fortunate that I was lucky enough to
start with outside directors and then
pull in someone who was an investor
because if I just gone into a VC
scenario or you know where everyone was
a paying customer I think it could've
been very intimidating I had never
chaired a corporate board before I had
no idea that it took a week to prepare
board books I had no idea that people
people didn't want to be there just to
have a rubber stamp it at least at
particularly early stage though women
can talk about this much with much more
experience than I but people are smart
and busy and care and they want to be
there spending their time helping you
think through something critical
and so that's how I Glover to my board
of directors like newsela I've built a
pretty large advisory board and it does
have some you know a couple dozen people
since beginning there now people have
different life cycles and different you
have different needs for different types
of people as a business evolves at least
I have and and so each advisory board
member right now I'm in a phase of
weighing potential partnership with a
strategic investor or a couple of their
major business development deals and
there's one advisor board member of mine
who's a classmate and venture capitalist
who's sort of been to this rodeo ten
times so I'm on the phone with her every
three days for half an hour for this
month then that might not talk her for
six months so you know I think that the
advisory board members in my mind are
there to cheer and be friends and be
sounding boards and each one has in my
from what we've chosen whether they were
wine experts like Pete Mondavi jr. or
whether they were Greg Waldorf of
eHarmony the CEO or whether it's people
someone who founded opinions calm I've
tried to people with different expertise
who had different skill sets to lend
some fundraising some marketing some biz
dev some financing summit you know all
that stuff so that that's how I've
focused my attention and bringing
together Board of Advisors and to how to
compensate them the board of directors
is equity and the Board of Advisors is
smiles sweating no no no literally like
baby oh yeah oh yeah you're just
sweating in you get off in short they
get wine dividends and they they think
I'm on dividends
and they get invited to that but once a
year for two days of wining and dining
where we make them sit in a room for one
of those days and think through five
major problems so it's like three board
meetings in one but I I honestly don't
know how I would have done it without
them
whether sort of charting recruit these
people for to be on your Board of
Advisors so different ways so the
classmates who were venture capitalists
is an easy one the close friend the
professors out of the GSB who had been
instrumental in helping shape pieces of
the product offering while here
we're also sort of easy ones the harder
ones were people where you wanted person
gave me advice of if you could have
anyone in the world who would it be
anyone I mean literally who do you want
to do this and the answer is if you
figure out who that person is and you
ask them once in a while you might get
lucky and they say yes which in some in
one case of mine they did and in another
case even I've heard from someone else
even if that person can't do it they
might have ideas that people who've
worked for them or work with and that
can do it so I think it's just about
good old-fashioned networking but really
how it was really more we started it was
more a pie chart of what kinds of skill
sets do we want to have on this advisory
board and then thinking about the
network and who would fit it and it's
pretty organic process I think as you're
researching a business plan or at least
as I was and talking to people about it
people who show keen interest and key
care and check back in and see how
you're doing are starting to form
informally serve as advisors and then
sort of like a dress rehearsal then you
ask them and if they're willing to do it
then it becomes is something a Christian
the crescendo of a conversation as
opposed to that's that's very eloquent
way of putting it it is and it's not
it's not I didn't just meet someone on
the street who I thought was great and
then you know scare him into you know
shock him with a question it was a
relationship a close relationship a
friend a professor a another mentor that
I had lunch or drinks or dinner with
multiple times and then it was almost
like you're already advising me how
could I not ask you to do this formally
and if for whatever reason they
couldn't or shouldn't do it formally
that was art that already been discussed
just keeping on the Board of Advisors
topic for now we can move on to the
board of directors how have you seen
entrepreneurs or CEOs use you
effectively as an advisor well I've been
currently on to small company board of
advisers and they've been over the
course in the last 15 years or so and
I've seen them I think it's a wonderful
strategy as Alissa mentioned to
determine what it is you need and those
needs change over time so initially it
might be someone who could help you put
together a really terrific business plan
maybe it's someone who knows about the
market you're targeting or it has some
product knowledge over time it can be
fun become fundraising etc etc and then
eventually going up to being you know
maybe having some expertise and
formalizing a corporate structure you
bring on a board of directors from the
outside etc so my my role generally has
been my I have a kind of a broad
background but generally it's been
around business planning I have had
friends who've asked me to come on board
and I've done it mainly because I'm
friends with them and I'm interested in
their product but primarily it's been
the relationship and then other times
I'm an expert in there in the target
market and it becomes it's maybe it's a
friend of a friend of a friend or
something right and I'll meet with them
and talk with them a few times and just
decide that's something I want to do and
I have the time for so I think that but
really defining your needs and
understanding that they change over time
I think is one of the most critical
elements of choosing good advisors
after that the intuition in my case of
place was really important so listening
to really your response to people or as
you're thinking through you know your
business issues and challenges you meet
random people and there is just this aha
moment that occurs to me like oh I gotta
get this person and I never think very
formally just approach them as I would
really like an hour of your time
whatever you can spare can I just tell
you what my problem is and as soon as
they get engaged that chemistry just
takes the life of its own so I would
urge you to be very intuitive and who
you pull in especially in the earlier
stages you know what you need you know
it's better than maybe putting it on
paper how many people do you have on
your Board of Advisors I've lost count
I have probably fifteen by now but as
the business evolved our needs changed
you don't ask them to go yeah yeah so
unless there's a real huge bad issue and
in one case though for the Board of
Advisors but not so for the board right
right you've got why well in one case a
technology advisor that we had actually
looked like maybe working for a
competitive company and in that case you
know I had a very fine conversation with
him I brought you on because of these
reasons
pick your horse basically and he picked
us so we had you know nothing to fear
from that perspective one of the
Articles that is assigned for reading
spoke to having term limits you know
term basically a term assignment for
advisors and directors saying that you
know that the highest value actually
comes when they just initially come on
the board at some point they kind of get
distracted lose interest that certainly
holds for a Board of Advisors Board of
Directors have in theory some kind of
fiduciary responsibility or frequently
investors and by definition this usually
have terms based on your corporation
documents but have you guys bad terms
with your board of adviser rules yeah
I've had terms with the board of
advisory roles that I've had some of
them your term doubt just because the
business didn't go anywhere other ones
get termed out because you're right the
the business change changes and I think
it's very good governance practice for
yourself to have those term limits even
for advisors because you never know when
somebody's really dysfunctional and it's
really how much you're willing to have
that honest conversation which sometimes
people have a very tired hard time
having and you know that about your own
personality term limits really help you
cut through that what looked it what do
you think is the right term because I
didn't do it in which I had two to three
years yeah two to three years I'm saying
and and I would say the term limits are
just to make sure everyone we're all on
the same page on this is it generally
you would have defined the term as a
couple few years three is really common
three years because it takes you a while
to get up to speed and understand what
the business is and then generally you
would say you serve for two three four
terms and then you're out regardless but
the nice part of that mechanism is that
every three years the conversation comes
up right and you either elect someone
again
jumped see that and that's what's really
nice and provide you a no being have the
conversation you see it much more
commonly with board directors things can
also be put in for a Board of Advisors
because I was going to comment that in
my business things move so fast and
three years as an eternity to company
Sherlock there to do it yeah you could
do two two years three two year terms so
if you really want some you know to have
that conversation every two years you
could but it gives you that opening a
year is pretty sure yeah unless you're
using them like a staff person sometimes
you advisors that's how I was used for
one is I was almost there every day like
an employee unemployed unpaid employee
which you know if it can work for the
skill that you need I think God for
people like you getting to the
conversation question do you do any
compensation for your board of advisers
or is the trip to Napa or the dinner
three nights in a row
I have honestly not and I've been very
upfront about that and the reason is is
that it is I think it's sort of karmic
right you know it people who want to see
you succeed the investment the payoff
not always is knowing that the time and
energy they're spending investing in you
and in your business is going to help it
move forward and if you show gratitude
in ways material or non and actually
show it and you know express it
I have exhorting in the way I've
experienced it has been payment enough
if there were to be a real win at the
end would I send the people who've been
the most helpful some ridiculous wine to
say thank you which is you know a
payment
yes I mean they've got the people who've
gone above and beyond no they have and
there's nothing I would want more than
to be able to compensate them and for
policy reasons it wouldn't be so clean
to give some equity and sum up not but
if at all they know that the gratitude I
feel and that I'll find a way to take
care of them some point in life but
directors we didn't do even for
directors we did equity of course but we
had that kind of awkward conversation
about how much and and so forth when we
first brought on someone who was a
paying customer the the bank
you know the investor director versus
not and it's a it's tricky so I think if
I could do it all over again I would
have had even clearer kind of policies
around as clear as they were for the
board advisors not paying anything I
would have been even more clear about
what the compensation structure was
going to be for the directors earlier
yes a hiring decision correct in our
case all of our advisors are compensated
with stock and it's uniformly done and
some of them I have compensated twice
because of the amount of time they've
spent really like unpaid employees and
in technology it's about the tenth of a
percent is typical and it usually comes
of course a form of stock that vests
over four years
now in terms of board of directors for
that to you because you have not taken
outside investors right now listen I can
address when you need one yeah
technically when you have employees you
have more than three employees you have
to have at least two board members okay
that's how my husband came to be but
that's a little kind of goes away when
we have serious money and investors
probably we will get more serious but
for now we have other fish to fry it I
find it it's terribly useful thing to do
as an early-stage company I I'm I'm a
big proponent of board meetings it is
literally like going to the dentist
every three months it is a ton it is it
is like you know it reminds you to floss
every day I mean it is a I'm serious I
think it's a crude metaphor but it's a
it's one of those things worth stopping
the music when things do move so fast
for early-stage companies to stop the
music just stop and just look at your
dashboards of what you were trying to
achieve and what you did and what you
didn't and you did all this in left
field but the core things might have
gotten left behind you know at least in
our cases of couple quarters and then
you get back to it or you decide that
the dashboard needs to shift that that
process of coming back and doing
something that's sort of painful and
takes a lot of time and pretty stressful
and all this but doing it
I have always also been grateful that we
did it right away
and a couple of our my classmates who
are entrepreneurs I know have done it
but did it later and they when they were
calling me for board books and saying
you know oh my god have you done this I
think you get a little bit particular if
you're a first-time entrepreneur I think
the board is pretty gracious about
giving you time to get your sea legs and
figure it out particularly the first
couple quarters whereas if you've been
operating this thing for two years
whether or not you'd ever done chaired a
corporate board before there's sort of
an expectation I think that by that
point you would have figured it out at
least how to run it so I found it useful
to use that that first year of being a
founder and CEO of a tech startup to
have a board of directors it was a great
let me just a phenomenal learning
experience and it's a phenomenal
discipline that of course public
companies have to go through but private
companies don't always have to and I've
been very grateful oh we have
I think the idea of flossing is a really
good one but you don't have to have a
board of directors but that's true so so
we are we are I have out of my investors
I have three that are particularly close
to the business and they are brutal in
their assessment of the business they
are like flossing cleaning I can go on
with the metaphor even further but we're
being fill I'm serious when they sit
down and my root canal absolutely and
they stop the music and say it's great
you're you know million miles a minute
whatever but what you said you were
going to do you haven't done and so it
doesn't have to be with the formal board
of director I have been a co-founder and
an executive member of multiple startups
that had very formal board meetings and
I have to say that it could go the other
way to where the preparation for the
board and the politics of it are just
just not worth spending time on and I
kind of came into this company with a
little bit of that baggage if you will
that hey I don't want to have a board
meeting that takes a little too
therefore if flossing is needed I gotta
be adult enough to do my own flossing
canal etc I chose these three people
because well they chose me they gave me
their money but but they actually
allowed me to be kind of a first-time
CEO I don't know should I do this should
I did I don't have this answer so they
were gentle with me but then it started
coming down and that was very helpful
Evelyn Elizabeth can you talk to kind of
some good practices you've seen in
early-stage entrepreneurs and how they
engage particularly their board of
directors one of the things that I found
to be most useful is and I've talked a
lot with entrepreneurs Department is
that no surprises policy
and I personally have a philosophy that
it's never too early for bad news and so
but so I don't like to be surprised and
particularly if it's bad and so if it's
on any subject really whether it's you
know revenue or development or
fundraising or whatever it is I'd rather
know earlier in the game so that I could
potentially help or at least get my mind
around it you know to to somehow help to
steer the company back on the right
track so that's one thing that I it's a
kind of a mindset that I bring in and
also I guess the other observation is
that I appreciated Alyssa's comments
about you know taking a break every now
and then every three months or whatever
to to just take stock of where you are
I think that's useful I don't know that
you know you absolutely have to stop
everything for a week to prepare or any
of that and ideally you'd be collecting
reports and documents that in general so
we and we've gotten better yeah yeah 75%
are kind of there and then you have some
additional stuff they have to prepare
for the board of directors or the Board
of Advisors but I do think that it's
extremely useful to just stop for a
moment and
anyway I would add to the no surprises
in fact it almost doesn't matter what
size board you have or what stage the
company is in we've instituted in some
of ours I'm on the board of America
style which is team clothing based out
of New York
they've got five billion in revenue we
instituted the 20 minute rule which
means if something bad happens it hits
the very top in 20 minutes that means
there's no filters because the problem
with filters is people trying to massage
it give it a little spin before it gets
to you and as you as a CEO depending on
having employees you have you're gonna
want to know that right away you don't
want it festering in the organization
because then you can't do anything about
it until it's too late so we and then to
the board right after that yeah how can
you give us an example is a problem so
so this would be the the problems that
we have have we had in there public
knowledge
because we had a investment so if you
have very trusted employees and you have
an employee who is stealing for me with
somebody else lights out you should know
about it your board of advisers should
know about it that's the no surprises
because it can hit the fan waves very
quickly and the way things happen
between Twitter and YouTube it's
surprising how much hits and Yelp it's
surprising how much hits the airwaves
yo and corresponding weapon to the board
as well yeah there's a CEO then have 20
minutes to get it to the board less than
that less than that I mean especially
it's an advisory role you have to have
some that you really trust in the
advisory role we call right away and say
we've got a problem give me your
thoughts on it
there was some conversation in the
article that we read about the right
number to be particular on the Board of
Directors I think the board of the
advisors I mean they're really not an
upper limit
what's your been been your experience
and what is the right number of folks on
the board of directors for us it's been
eight to nine eight to nine board
members partly because anything larger
than that it's tough to get a decision
made so you really want eight to nine
board members it also allows you to
separate into committees if you're gonna
do committee work typical committees or
audit committees most of them have
governance and nominating committee in
the compensation committee those are the
top three and then depending on the kind
of industry you're in if your technology
sometimes your committee just focused on
the technology so eight to nine works
really well the decisions made without
having to try to corral 15 people 15 is
15 eight
now even I was on the board of longs
drugs which was another five billion
dollar company and I didn't say that I
know the boards that on which I
currently serve our generally nine but
seven to nine for a public company and
that can go up into the billions of in
revenue but also for smaller companies
I'd say five to seven maybe but and
that's counting the CEO so you'd have
four to six and generally people have an
odd number because then you don't have a
job you tiebreaker vote on difficult
subjects so you have an odd number of
Directors generally and it's great it's
a great number in fact you know if we've
been more recently saying someone came
in a new strategic came in who wouldn't
want it necessarily to be even for the
paper mentioned reasons so my business
partner and I are both on the board
right now so she you know potentially
she would step off or we'd figure
something else because so no actually we
had so two of the directors are here my
business partners in New York my team is
here and I'm of course here and then the
director who so my business partner
travels here but also the the director
who joined us a year plus ago who wrote
the big check is in Chicago and he
travels and he travels so we do it in
Napa at Jack's winery and have a great
lunch after the prize but but yeah we do
it they do travel and I have done one
board meeting as a call and there is no
substitute for getting five people in a
row and looking him in the eye and
having a conversation I mean I really
really really didn't do not like having
people call in it just changes the whole
dynamic
that's why they keep its cool even for
large companies because you get a better
chance of getting everybody's calendar
finding the same date to get them there
for the face
but but for the advisory board I would
only get them all together once a year
and getting and then that relationship
is managed much more one-on-one where
it's a one-on-one column I mean
basically having their bylaws that as a
member of the board of directors you
need to be present for board meetings
yes I mean make sure that they report it
yeah and yeah the expectation was you
can make the in-person meetings I do
think that with committee meetings
sometimes or with short subjects I do
think that that particularly if it's
something that's been discussed before
you can have an effective phone call
meeting you know that can work but but
it's it you're right that nothing is a
substitute for it first
yeah and for quick triaging the bad new
stuff that you share within 20 minutes
that you know is something that needs
it's an action item and it has a
conversation I have definitely have
board calls that have been 30 minutes
that we get people on the phone but for
a four hour we're gonna swap through
major things that's that I found I would
definitely next time put it in the
bylaws this one to suggest it's I mean I
haven't had a huge problem but it you
know it's a challenge
that's right for outside board of
directors what's the proper compensation
with a privately held early-stage
company
well I'll comment my experience has been
arranging from near-zero with equity
only to you know with with no real no
solid of course perceived value of the
equity eventually you don't you you hope
right - I was involved in a smaller
company wasn't right at start of what I
joined it shortly thereafter early stage
that then grew to be a hop couple
hundred million dollars over the sixth
year I was on it and it was practically
healthy back in time and then they they
then sold it and it was five thousand
dollars a year in cash and some equity
I'm thinking me it was ten thousand
shares a year or something Oh was it
hardly even half a percent quarter
percent low we take what we do quarter
point for director per annum for outside
directors we go outside during yeah we
didn't actually measure and I don't
remember because it was a few we sold it
a few years ago board role and Starbucks
right so I came around that there's a
big range one more question that I'm
going to open it up this class obviously
is all women with a the top of the class
being entrepreneurship from the
perspective of women are there issues
specific to women as they recruit their
boards of advisors and boards of
directors that they should consider
doesn't matter what you get on the board
as long as it's got that still you need
well so I'll speak to my experience
before juniors before the company that
I'm running right now I think if you're
a woman and if you're not and if you're
one of the executives and you're not one
of the founders board of director makes
a huge difference
the way they perceive you how much
you're in in the conversation of course
CEO matters a lot and how close you are
to the CEO and suffer but so that's one
extreme kind of where being a woman I
think you really have to watch what the
board's perspective is of you because
ultimately every month you're in front
of them you should evaluate them as
potential bosses do I get along with
them do they understand me outside in a
smaller company it matters less and it's
really about how much of a go-getter you
are to go get the Board of Advisors or
board of directors who you can can mess
at the sales process if you will and and
the first person I approach the very
famous person my very first Board of
Advisors person it's very famous person
I was all nervous she's actually a
graduate of the GSB
I was like and so she finally reached
across put her hand over my hand said
you want me to be an advice
I said it's okay
it's a tenth of a percent none of the
equity is that okay I said yes and she's
a contemporary she's not an older person
or you know I think this year last week
she said same story no no we timed it
that way I mean there's been some
discussion I've heard some folks say as
a woman if you're gonna have one woman
on your board of directors you need to
so somebody's not singled out as the
woman Board of Directors I mean I just
throw that out see if you have any
response to that being on a board then
so I'm gonna board for this all men and
we're opening up another Court seat
because once retiring and I'm insisting
it's another women on the board because
I do find as a woman on a board it's
helpful to have another woman up
otherwise as a woman I wouldn't
necessarily say if I was a woman CEO
looking for a board member that I would
necessarily hang out a woman
though you know I think they're great so
it's just the skill that I'd be looking
for but as a woman on a board just for
another woman well just to follow up I
just expand on that and Evelyn could
chime in I'm on three public boards and
I'm the only woman and I've been the
only woman on these boards and there's
something about well on one of the
boards last week case is a contemporary
story I walked in and the head of the
Governance Committee okay so this is the
committee is supposed to be you know
setting the rules of how you you know
things behave and all that stuff he said
Oh Liz I get hard to hardly wait to see
what shoes you wore and if they matched
your jacket this time and I kind of
pause for a second and I just thought
okay all right what do I say and I said
you know me too
I just love that little number you had
on last time and he was like this is in
front of the guys guys
so he's but you know it's um it's really
nice if you get a little bit more of a
balance of balance and energy and with
one woman you're the only one and and
you're you know I feel I have a feel
like I have a lot to contribute it I'm
respected in most situations however I
I'm a low woman I think very clearly and
I also find it
we tend to use our intuitive skills
really well in the room and we sense
what's happening in the room right and
the guys just don't have another woman
in the room and you sense there's
something wrong if you look at another
woman in the room and she senses the
same thing you guys have this flashing
signal between the eyes that you know
and so both of you can bring up the
issue and you won't feel so isolated by
bringing in isolation
it's the isolation that you get even
though they try to try to be good but
you know I I'm a lot older than I really
look because of my Asian skin so so but
but sometimes the men treat you as a
nice or you know a favorite daughter
rather than the contributing member that
you are so again it always helps to have
another woman in the room because you
reinforce each other and you reinforce
your contribution that's super
interesting I mean from an entrepreneurs
perspective being obviously women who
founded a company whose business
partners also a woman I I literally was
just looking at skillset I swear it
didn't even occur to me maybe it's
generational
I don't know I was looking for skillset
these guys were there the age difference
is they could be my father's there's
complete respect maybe that's you know
they want help for that reason it all
works in my current situation to my
advantage I have no problem whatsoever
having an all-male board except for us
honestly none at all um I can see though
I do have another woman in the room and
it is my business partner so like I mean
that I cannot Amman
imagine not having and that I could
definitely see being strange on a board
you're the vision you're the idea you
know different relationships right yes
yeah I think a problem in the room I
think the probabilities all I have a
great relationship with these guys have
known him for three years it would be
different if I were walking into a cold
yeah that doesn't that doesn't freak me
out either I think what but it but it
makes me mindful if I for the next one
if there is no business partner or a
male business partner or whatever the
case may be of making sure there's a
woman at four I would counsel you to be
mindful of this I don't know at what
stage of business you're in now but as
you see it ramped up and grow there will
be a point where somebody will think
can't she really run it and at that
point you really want supporters
depending on with your goals or maybe
you want to pass it on and say you know
I love starting but I don't like running
huge but just be careful because I have
so many friends that have started
companies and venture people coming in
would tell her or we investment if
you're out or Gables they won't say that
they would invest and then six months
down the road address Bank
you know yeah nicely or not so nicely
removed and I think that's where being a
woman comes in as a is an entrepreneurs
you know when things get really good
when you're sitting there and saying wow
you know good job is you have to think
about whether you you know what is your
relationship with your board and whether
you trust them to back you I don't know
if guys have that problem I haven't had
the chance to ask people wonder if it is
worse for women I don't know
any questions what they're doing for you
but I'm having trouble with kind of the
balance between the formality and the
informality is feels like actually they
can go both ways sometimes like I'm
hearing sometimes it's actually sort of
like a mentor relationship that's a
little bit formalized things I'm curious
what's events that have actually
formalizing it and saying like can you
be my mentor or can you be on my board
advisors its credibility credibility
because otherwise it's a piece of paper
and an idea and something you're out
there floating in the wind trying to
start but all of a sudden you've got the
circle of people with at least in my
case far more life experience and
credibility than I had and whose
association with me and this venture all
of a sudden shored up the validation of
going for it that's why you do it right
all of a sudden if three all-stars in
technology and the wine world are
spending their time and lending their
name and being publicly on a website
that's searchable by google wait a
second it's not just some GSB alum with
an idea you know out of Silicon Valley
it's now has legs so that that's to me
the reason to do it
and and how you use that you have to be
very careful because depending on who
your advisor is that goes also for
funding partners in my case some of them
are very careful with their reputations
so you want to be very careful about how
you use it of course you don't want to
be like a little kid always running but
you want to be very careful and they are
your credibility when it's nothing but a
set of PowerPoint slides and I should
have been more clear
half of our mine Advisory Board members
come on 1/3 to 1/2 our investors so
these are people who believed in me and
gave money and they've been right enough
we're now kind of 10% or 15% board of
directors for although they for
mentioned reasons so this was a way for
me to acknowledge their support without
walking around saying hey this guy's an
investor in my company and it's also a
way for them to it also helps and that's
it makes it takes it from a totally
passive angel investment to a somewhat
active investment just by the virtue of
the fact that it's you should have
publicly out it not all my investors are
on my advisory board they don't they
don't they shouldn't all be and the ones
that had value to add that was directly
relevant are but that's the other piece
of the story that a lot of angel backed
companies do because you're not going to
put everyone on your big board
right you also mentioned the value of a
mentorship piece and specifically for
your board ELISA for the ones that are
like CEOs of these big name companies
you know Netflix eHarmony do you find
that they have the time to commit to the
to the drug crimes the advisory board
the same level as some of the other
individuals so the way I treat their
relationships is that it's not it's very
different from a board of directors
where it's regular there's monthly you
know in some cases bi-weekly or monthly
email updates there's quarterly meetings
it's a it's an ongoing consistent evenly
consistent conversation and most there's
bad news which I hear about immediately
because you have to and they're very
helpful and helping you think through it
in terms of an advisory board I have
much more of a go fetch philosophy it's
like they're there I need something and
I go get them and then I'm in LA and I
ask if there's any way they could
squeeze me in for two hours for brunch
and they do or I know you're slammed
you're trying to do five deals right now
your investments are going sideways I
need to I need 90 minutes of your time
anywhere anytime name them you know I'm
there so it's it's a different type of
relationship whereas they're
accommodating me but it's if they're
signing up to help to be drafted at some
moment they understand that that's going
to happen but as long as you're
respectful of their time and work around
it and the location I haven't had
problems getting it
as an advisor and also calling on boards
of advisers or even boards of directors
is if you have someone who's very very
seasoned who has deep expertise in
something that's relevant okay which
would be a good definition for a board
of advisor maybe throwing you a little
bit of money
it's a I had a call about two weeks ago
from a guy I'm on his Board of Advisors
he has a startup company and he said and
I'm I'm do a lot of work in the
executive compensation and equity
ownership and that kind of thing on
boards and I'm on and we went out for
drinks kind of just as friends and he
said so Liz were thinking we're selling
the company and we're thinking and they
want to keep on the management team how
much equity ownership and the new
business should we have and I said oh I
don't know somewhere between 18 and 23
percent he said okay good you know done
exactly but info you know so so it was
kind of you know like that so that was
my value add in that moment and and so
you know that's Lou's gonna go negotiate
he it saves him a ton of time so if you
have those people in the CEO of eHarmony
or whatever you know they they can
answer a very very particular question
and save you like weeks and months of
work even boards of advisors will do
that for you so I'm involved with one
where we want to sell a piece of the
company
and they've already met with potential
buyer who I happen to know so the CEO
called me up they okay what can you tell
me about this group why why are they
interested in buying what's their stick
and how should I approach it and so
that's the kind of advice so you guys
more credibility more experience than
somebody who you know maybe they're
retired you know individual that has you
know infinite time in the worlds and
they work with you but I would I would
strongly urge you should go for name
credibility but someone who's actively
in the business in some way or form or
shape you don't want somebody who does
this as a hobby because they may enjoy
certain aspects of you know meeting up
with you learning about new things
that's it but you don't have time for
that you want somebody who will you know
tell you 18 to 23 percent now go and I
only have 15 minutes for you go yeah of
course she's retired so there's a range
there is a point they were more
interested so I enjoy a very clear line
between being having a mentor
these boards of advisers I'm a lot more
formal with my board of advisers I have
a particular ask they are there because
yes it was intuitive but it was
intuitive towards the product it was
intuitive towards needing to know how I
can do a better presentation or you know
financing issues or what not but but you
are asking them for particular expertise
and you are not there to you know open
yourself up and say I feel
who do you ask people that I came across
in the fundraising journey over time
who's loved the idea I got really
passionate about I thought I was going
in there to have a fundraising
conversation and maybe was and it became
very obvious it didn't take you know
that much intuition realized the
financial circumstances had changed in
their personal life or it wasn't the
space for them to write a check but they
were really really really getting it and
and those were people also at times that
I ended up asking to advise I'm a bit
great
other questions
what are you fighting at someone on your
board isn't
recently
and
I'm sorry I didn't hear the first
brother waiting someone on your board
Oh
that's right well yeah for the board of
directors if they're this is it there's
there's gradations I guess in that if
they're actually obstructionist and
having destructive conversations or
something not all supportive and a block
then you might need to take action and
actually remove them I was running a
company where we we took out I like she
said Fraser took out of the original
nine members of the board eight not
counting me only one still remained at
the end of two years Oh
for various reasons I won't tell the
stewardess or did stories but but I just
had really hard but direct conversations
they had all said when I came in look we
know we serve at your behest and you
know bunch of stuff but it was early you
know they weren't up for a reelection
sometimes you can do that with the board
of directors you do actually have a
reelection in a few years or every house
every year yeah so you can remove them
every year and ideally that's what you'd
have a conversation and say our needs
have changed thank you so much for
service it's been terrific again if you
don't say I think we're going to have a
different slate this year it's time to
make a change any of those phrases will
work
it's a CEO and sometimes if you've got a
good leave director on your board the
lead director have that conversation
with push-out oh yeah oh sure sure I had
one board member who refused to retire
and wanted to change the term limits in
the retirement age tarneja 72 well he
always felt asleep at 3 o'clock in the
afternoon so nap time so anytime you
forgot that we had agreed to do
something I said oh it was 3 o'clock
sleep but he wanted to extend the term
limits of 72 its retirement age and he
wasn't extended beyond that he'd already
been grandfathered in once before so he
wanted to extend it again and the board
didn't want to come up against him
because he was one of the old-timers in
there so I had to be the one who was
presiding over the board to tell him
this is good governance practice we're
sticking to this we've made it public
that this is the retirement age so you
would be in doing a disservice to the
organization by saying
yeah there are a lot of tough
conversations stuff come
your partner founder in this panel I'd
like to hear more about managing
through your board especially I mean
women
more collaborative and consensus
building and I know that's something
that's my part is when there is
agreement you know I know
ultimately we can call the for vote but
it still feels weird when you know you'd
rather you know you can trust our
decision because everyone breathes
rather than calling it more votes
because if you call it board vote it
also does this story some of the dynamic
we have on your board so I'd love to
hear more about that and how you manage
conflict and if you
your story first I'll tell myself well
you know people people on boards are
human beings right so everything you see
in life you see in the board room almost
everything right and so you see all
kinds of really interesting behavior
characters in all kinds of stuff there's
gonna be stuff that comes up so I would
I do think it's it's almost always
better to take the high road and try to
work through to an agreed decision and
then take a vote you know not who in
ugli all the time because that takes a
lot of energy and it also leaves a lot
of scars okay so you can always do that
but it's you should save that after
trying some other things I was on a
board that I was a card new board that
was appointed to last year in mid-year
and was my first board meeting and I was
appointed the head of the Compensation
Committee it's one of the things that I
focus on on boards and much to my
surprise although I've just been
recruited the we in the executive
session following the open board meeting
the board only - the CEO and the members
of management we had a meeting and it
came out that the rest of the board had
been thinking about actually had decided
to replace the CEO
then told me this in the interviewing
process and so so I I kind of you know I
said well what led to this got me bit of
the story and then it turns out that the
chairman of the board was leaving for
Europe the next day and the head of the
Governance Committee was leaving for
Hawaii on Saturday this is Thursday and
so neither of them could tell the CEO
that he had to go and so kind of like
Speaker of the House you know when the
president and whoever else is gone
they said Liz you're next in line to
tell us Monday that's why yeah send
Korea that's right
she'll do it so I said you know I fired
a lot of people I can do that you know I
okay so I did it and then I had to
negotiate him out with the contracts and
the interns having negotiated the new
CEO in so my first two weeks on the
board were spent doing all this scut
work basically there are ways to do it
as gracefully as one can give him the
circumstances that that was a pretty
significant issue and then I had to
circle back I talked to the board about
why they left me with that and
you know how that happened when they say
they said we didn't want to do it so I
started the story a little bit earlier
about the guy that didn't want to leave
and the rest of the board did not want
to confront him and because for exactly
what you said they didn't want to stir
up the dynamics inside the organization
and have bad feelings even though the
guy was leaving right but they did want
to have bad feelings against each other
and because they also thought to the
members of the seven-member board would
vote for him to extend the term and then
the others wouldn't
so like Liz I had to be the one going in
there but I approached it from a
governance point of view so I said okay
we set rules a while ago about when our
retirement age was going to be we've
already grandfathered you in once before
and it's public knowledge we wouldn't
look good from a PR point of view the
heightened governance behind SEC
inquiries and - are you following your
governance practices yada yada yada
so that's the attack I took at the end
of the day you wanted a payment because
at this point in time it was a mutual
fund company mutual funds don't pay
stock so he wanted the payment so we
agreed for a one-year consulting fee so
he would get paid half the stipend and
it was two hundred thousand dollars at
the time so half of that $100,000
consultant
and he left it it was fine lots of times
it comes down to money yeah it does you
know it's a lot easier if you don't pay
somebody to leave it's sad to say but
you have one more question place up
something curious about the timed
expectations when you join a board when
you're asking some of these
persons that I work for me you know my
behalf several hours a week are they
just going to show up at the meeting you
know what what's the expectation of both
I would say the advisory board and it's
even Chocula that's more informal but
I'm just curious about what the
expectation
how much certain ever I don't know it's
super informal like they're our friend
is they caught you know an advisory
board just calls you to check in and how
you're doing I mean once in a while if
you've had a very coach you onto
something and then you know they want to
know how it went cuz they're thoughtful
people they'll call back but let's see
how it went but realistically in my
experience with either or it's you drive
the level of engagement as the CEO so
you say I mean there's an expectation on
a board that you will come totally
prepared to a board meeting and
thoroughly read a board book and I've
gotten hammered for only giving people a
couple days to read it they've busy live
you got to get these things out a week
in advance and obviously if you're an
advisor you need I need an hour of your
time I have to as I've already mentioned
work around your schedule but I think
the time commitment probably varies by
the nature of the company and the
problem and the role in the past you
serve and obviously as I speak more to
that on a consistent basis over time but
I think it it varies by also what
company's going through so if if it's if
you're just been funded and things are
cruising and they know you've got a year
runway and they know that it's about
execution you might give status reports
and then wait to the next board meeting
if you're negotiating potential you know
strategic deals running out of cash
needing to get rid of someone in a
dispute with some of your contractors
these are these are things that
necessitate frequent conversations so I
think as long as in my experience you're
upfront about what your needs are and
you communicate them it the the timing
it shakes out naturally
for formal boards of directors paid
position is really a job and there are
you know requirements against what you
hire people and it's always you always
outline in a lot of detail what the time
requirements are so there's five six
four five six seven meetings a year
they're generally two days you tell them
the location you tell them actually for
a year ahead of time when you're
recruiting what those dates are so if
they need it right and and then the
expectation is it would be fully
prepared and if there's a committee
service and you talk about that and it's
you know it's it's it's not like
full-time work where you basically
expect someone the full time you know
all the time so that's so you have to
lay it out very explicitly and I even
think that for advisory board members I
think it's great to set an expectation
you know I'll call you from time to time
on issues or I like to get people
together once a year and NAFA you know
whatever it is because everybody you
know has other stuff we have a very
formal specific document for the board
of advisers and it says for this amount
of
you are committing and I believe it's
two hours per month plus an additional
twice a year
half-day meeting there's you know it's
specified like that now do we hold them
to the two hours not really sometimes
depending on what we're going through it
may be you know a full day or it may be
just 15-minute calls but back-to-back
multiple days basically you pull them
and you drive what you need to get huge
issue but our attorneys suggested that
we specify here's the stock package and
here's what I'm asking you to do so in
case of a dispute there is something to
fall back on and board members recognize
that if you're going through an
acquisition which we've both done you
could be on call almost every day and
you're going through that's a transition
so it could take you know I've been on
four or five hour calls every week
thanks for coming